as years went on and when all the things
went wrong in our life and i started
looking back i honestly don't know if he
loved anything or anybody you know uh
like greg jr i could see the love with
his kids i could see how he treats other
people did he come out already or he's
he's got it he's out i've been talking
to him we've got together a few times uh
how is your personality is the two of
you guys together relationships well
very similar he's he's i like to think
i'm easygoing he is uh he he likes to
laugh you know his father likes to laugh
too
he's easy to talk to and he's caring
he's caring here's the perfect example i
had to borrow money from greg senior
probably
200 times as a kid you know
not once did i not pay vague
really yes not once
even during the war we had to pay big no
breaks nothing okay
greg jr on the other hand i might have
borrowed money from him three times
didn't charge me a penny get out of here
he says you're my brother what's matter
of you and i'm saying to myself
well i see you know so you fell a little
further than the from the tree and
people thought that's yeah when did greg
know about you and linda
greg jr yeah oh not until the arrests we
all got arrested
and
uh
i
exploded that out there because i had so
much resent for his father
scarborough yeah because ultimately he
was you know a 30-year informant which
we'll get to i'm sure
and
i was fighting my case
okay later on
i had no intentions of i was gonna make
a deal figure something out 20 years 18
years we're fighting it
but
one by one the council year flips that's
carmine cesar who i was fighting for
uh other
guys good fellas and captains
finally it comes out that greg senior my
mentor the guy that brought me into this
that everything
is a government informer for 30 years
okay
and while i'm on the floor with the real
boss junior persico son ali boy
he tells me him and his father knew
about greg for 20 years get out of here
i
you know what when he told me that the
cd reaction you just had that must have
came on my face because he turned white
after he said it and he just knew he
made a mistake
terrible thing to tell me that you guys
knew
whether he meant they surmised or they
knew doesn't even matter because people
say well maybe they thought i've seen
guys get killed for a lot worse
so if you really thought it that's
enough to kill him in that life i hate
to say it okay i saw greg i watched greg
shoot a guy
that called him a rat
but tried to renege on it at the desk
like we are now i got up out of my chair
when this guy came in he sat down donnie
his name was
and
greg took care of his business he took
his money from the guy wrote his name
down crossed him off the list like he
paid
and he says donnie what's this right
here i'm a rat
donny turned white he started sweating
he knew he was in trouble
i was standing in the room with greg jr
carmine bobby and one other person grant
junior carl my bum oh and me four of us
were in there were four guys in the room
but i was sitting at the chair as always
i got up to let him sit down and i would
stand right by the door you know until
he left i'd go back and sit with greg
as soon as the guy said he didn't have
paperwork he was just talking drunk with
another guy i don't mean that you know
better greg bubba bye you don't have no
paperwork you can't prove that he says
no
of course not reaching his desk the
drawer right there
popped them right across the table kill
them yep that was the first time i
actually saw somebody get rolled up in a
rug
and carried out
literally
and the funny thing is i had to go with
bobby to pick out a new carpet to put
down
and
the color he picked he's colored blind
bobby
we didn't know that he brings an orange
carpet back the last carpet was dark
brown
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you